hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the capablanca
saga will at the conclusion of the
Capablanca saga and yes I have found my
book here it is their habit the book
we've been using to cover this saga by
Edward winter really an awesome book and
suffice it to say it was not well at a
place where one would keep books but
since I already ordered the second one
it's it's a new copy really it's really
an amazing book I will do a giveaway
once it arrives so I'll keep you posted
on that but we're gonna have a like EU
comment in a video and then you can win
this book it's really really just an
awesome book so I don't need to I will
give away one of them so that being said
we've really done a lot of capablanca
videos that this is the 85th video in
the cup of Wonka saga the conclusion
video and we've covered a lot of topics
from a couple on has used his match
against national Cuban champion Quan
Corzo then his match against Frank James
Marshall really an epic match where
kappa blanka just obliterated a Marshall
then Marshall helped him get in his
first big international tournament of
San Sebastiano in 1911 Capablanca was
victorious there as well then he had his
even bigger tournament in a song theater
burg where he almost won but Emmanuel
Oscar went into beast mode and in the
end Capablanca finished second then we
covered some of the exhibition games he
had some of simultaneous games here we
had his famous game against composer
Sergei Prokofiev then we had the 1916
rising him into New York than the 1918
New York tournament then the match
against the border costed his five-game
match which I really enjoyed as you know
it really sounds strange when someone
says yeah he just you know totally
obliterated him 5 to 0 but if you
actually look at the game there was much
more to that and then we finished it off
with which showing all the games from
the map from the 1921 World Chess
Championship match Capablanca vs. Lasker
so that's pretty much it capablanca is
world champion and now there is this I
think that capablanca really hated of
course last but published the book on
the championship and this World
Championship match every
was looking forward to it but it didn't
really get any media coverage well it
did a little bit but not much
because Alaska specifically stated that
he and Capablanca owned the copyrights
to the games played in the World
Championship match so no one could show
the games magazines you know they said
yes the game was played it was very nice
but I don't think if they were even
allowed to say was very nice they just
said the game was played
but when Lasker finally published his
book he said every a you know he
presented everything about the match in
that book the situation before the match
the situation after the match the the
negotiations but capablanca really
dislike that well last but pretty much
lied in his book and on multiple
occasions he missed out some of the very
important parts of the negotiations
which if you were following the saga
from the beginning you know them a lot
of things like elastro was offended that
Capablanca objected to one of his terms
during the first part of the
negotiations and the last person said
that he will not play a World
Championship match against anyone who
offends him and then Alaska appointed a
special arbiter just to like check out
did Capablanca in fact you know insult
to dr. Lasker and then when the arbiter
that last PowerPoint is said no
everything is fine then Lasker said that
he still doesn't agree with him and that
he will not play a World Championship
match against someone who is well
insulting like capablanca so those were
only the little parts but then in the
book Alaska also states that well as you
can see the quote above the board if dr.
Lasker wants an excuse for his defeat he
should look for it where the facts are
not against him so he complained about a
lot of things during the match like the
the heat and the Sun there is one
section in the book that I would very
gladly read to you so here it is
it's one of the things that Capablanca
also mentions so Capablanca says again
in his letter of 18th april page 24 he
as dr. Lasker complained of the Sun and
this time of the heat also he
claims that for the afternoon
temperature was 32 degrees Celsius in
the shade and capablanca says that
that's that's a wonderful imagination
but such temperatures do not exist in
Cuba except in midsummer in August the
hottest month of the year and also last
proclaims that it was a 29 degrees
Celsius at night with fresh north wind
Capablanca states that this is again
absurd when the north wind blows in Cuba
at the at this time of the year at night
the temperature cannot be more than 20
degrees Celsius and the probabilities
are that the temperatures would be below
20 degrees Celsius and in such cases one
feels chilly capablanca says I remember
that on two occasions we had to close
the window because the air was too cool
yet he claims it was too hot it might be
well to state right here that far from
being used to the hot water as most most
people think I cannot stand it so a
couple monkey himself hates the Cuban
water he says that I have spent most of
my life in very cold climates and while
I enjoy cold weather hot weather makes
me ill the truth is that that we played
under the most ideal conditions
imaginable we played at the casino which
is situated next to the country club and
about three-quarters of a mile from the
beach we had a separate room with the
windows in three sides and the gardens
at the back where we often walked while
the other was thinking a waiter was put
solely for our use so they could you
know just ask for the waiter to bring
them anything and s kappa blanka says it
was free of charge we could have
anything quickly and free of charge we
played only at night one session of four
hours from 9:00 to 1:00
the weather was excellent not for a man
of the tropics only but for a European
as well so here a couple uncle says that
he like he doesn't agree with a lot of
things last / said in the book and that
he recommends his own book about the
match
I haven't found these two books the one
that Alaska published and the one that
Capablanca publish probable Anka didn't
write it it was it was his version but
he was not the writer I still have
problems locating those
books online if they even exist anymore
but okay Alaska also complained about
the weight loss that he he couldn't eat
properly and that he also fell sick and
Capablanca says that he also lost some
more than ten pounds during during the
match and that he also didn't eat very
well because he was he was stressed out
you know the nerves and everything you
can't just have a proper meal all the
time but all in all as per then
complained that capablanca didn't treat
him properly after he became world
champion that at the party for example
after the World Chess Championship match
well they just they just didn't behave
like they should and also that
capablanca said that he didn't believe
him that Alaska fell ill in one such
occasion capablanca says that he's not a
like a doctor or someone with medical
expertise but that lasts three days
after the match that Lasker sail for
Europe and that he was looking very well
and very healthy so it's I mean it's a
clash of opinions a lot of things were
happening back then it's hard to
pinpoint what was exactly going on but
the part about negotiations that last
were left out in his book are very clear
and they are available to the public
even today you know in very high detail
so that's that's pretty much it for that
regard so couple unko really hated
Laskaris version of the book and if I
managed to find these two versions of
the book I will I will try to acquire
them and go through them as I'm very
interested in this myself so also one of
the things kappa blanka said that he
will try to change when he becomes world
champion
well now that he is a world champion
that he will try to make the world
championship game send all of the games
from big matches finished in one sitting
so not like we'll play for hours now
then we're gonna have three hours of
rest then we're gonna play two hours in
the evening then if the game lasts too
long we're gonna have an adjournment
maybe we'll finish it tomorrow or maybe
next Saturday he says that that's that's
a very bad format for the public the
public you know for the working class
for example they have free time now they
can't
we watch the game now have a rest for
three hours come back watch it evening
evening I mean some people can but most
people can and couple Blanca says that
that's a that's a very poor format for
holding Watchers Championship match so
okay you cannot avoid the German I mean
you could like we do it today we but
today we have engine so we cannot
adjourn games but in those days I was it
was normal to adjourn games so and it
was only one of the things that couple
danke said that he will try to change
and make it better for not only the
chess players but for the game of chess
itself and for the for the chess public
so yeah
that's also one of the things I wanted
to mention and also couple Blanca was
publicly well not not criticized but
joseph henry blackburn the black death
who was 80 years old at the time said
that it's a shame that the games in that
match looked the way they were as joseph
henry blackboard called it it was a
superior wood shifting and meaning that
Capablanca adopted lasker style and that
the games were very boring and that he
did not enjoy that world championship
match which is which is to be expected
joseph henry blackburn was eight years
old at the time and when he was young
and when he was you know destroying
people like like dynasty in great style
capablanca says that it's simply not
possible to play like that in this match
and that a couple Blancas match in his
score in his match against Lasker speaks
for itself he could play like fancy
shiny combinations in in several of the
games he had against Lasker but those
combinations allow for mistakes and
would it you give Lasker chances and
then a couple Blanca says that okay I
could have played fancy and I could have
sacrificed pieces went for some fierce
attacks but then I might have lost the
match and the no one would said yeah
Capablanca is better he just lost the
match because he played fancy moves they
would say yeah Lasker is the superior
player as they did every time Lasker won
a match and up and up until this point
everyone the general opinion was that
Alaska was unbeatable in in in match
format in tournament format as well but
simply here and he said that well Joseph
Henry Blackburn is also one of the
players who has a negative score against
the Emanuele ask her amongst the pretty
much everyone else except Capablanca now
and that he really doesn't feel it
necessary that Capablanca has to explain
himself that the older masters well had
the Black Death himself does not really
understand the mastery of younger
players today much like you know someone
from the from the era of Bobby Fischer
and Michael Todd wouldn't really enjoy a
game watching the game I don't know
played between a course and in Maxim
Varela Grove you know some 50 move draw
that was a brilliantly played like like
an engine I mean maybe they would who
knows but it's pretty much it's pretty
much like that
like Joseph Avery Blackburn watching a
game between Alaska and couple Blanca
he's like that they're just you know
showing off their fancy defensive
strategy you know what no one is trying
anything but a couple wonka knows that
he had to adopt this style and that once
he got a positive result in Game five
that he was gonna stick with it as his
he wants to win the match here and it's
not only about winning the match because
if you remember Alaska said that he
resigns the title in that cup of lanka
is now the champion but capablanca
refused he had to travel to europe twice
to convince doctor last quarter to play
the magic because he did not want to
take the title away from last group
without a fight something that happened
to anatoly karpov when bobby fischer
declined to fight in the World Chess
Championship match and Karpov had spent
the rest of his life practically you
know proving to the public that he is
you know a worthy successor to the title
so Capablanca did not want that he
wanted a fair fight and he won a fair
fight so that's also something I wanted
to mention here and yeah that's that's
pretty much it capablanca is now world
champion we're not gonna be continuing
the saga we could you know continue or
all of all of the years up until the
match with Alex on the radio and then
hear his later years his you know three
visits to the Russia were he he had
impressive results
there are a lot more tournaments
Capablanca played were there we could
show but I decided that we're gonna
shorten the sagas up until the moment
where someone becomes a world champion
so this is a witness we ended the cup of
Blanca Saga and if you're wondering why
there's a Richard the ready here along
with Jose Blanc I decided to show a
small miniature here at the end of this
video so I do hope you will enjoy that
as well so it's it's just a game one a
very nice miniature played by by
capablanca or maybe ready we don't know
who won this game so let's just show it
without much analysis as there isn't all
that much to analyze but we're gonna
show it nevertheless so II for beretti
we have a 5 by capablanca Knight to f3
with Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the
reuleaux PES is on the board and now
d6 the old Stein is defense with c3 by
DT and now a6 pushing the best back rush
up to a4 and now f5 my Capablanca
wanting to put the F or F pawn before
developing his Knight
we have d4 by ready and now comes F
captures on e4 and now Knight to g5 so a
very aggressive opening by white and
this is something kappa blanka usually
thrives that he says ok throw everything
you have against me I'm just gonna break
it down and show you how how the
position really is simple with he
captures on d4 by kappa blanka Knight
captures on e4 now grabbing back the
pawn and now Knight to f6 offering a
trail of Knights reti develops a bishop
pinning Capablanca Knight now
threatening to capture and Bishop to e7
Capablanca defense and now we have Queen
captures on d4 as the knight is pinned
which is a really bold move as
Capablanca has b5 what do you do that
well Capablanca went b5 he says ok I'm
also interested what you have here and
now Knight captures on f6 width check G
captures on f6 now both of red TC
bishops are under attack da for Bishop
and the g5 Bishop and he goes Queen to
d5 now threatening to win the night with
check and threaten the rook here so what
do you play here s Capablanca Capablanca
decided he's gonna capture da for Bishop
be captures on a for and now you can to
just go for the night if you capture
with Czech Bishop attacks the rook is
guarded by the Queen the the Queen has
to move and next move you're just gonna
whatever the Queen plays you're just
gonna capture this guy here and your
piece and the White doesn't have a good
compensation so instead a ready went for
Buster to h6 just keeping capablanca
King in the center and now if ready can
bring his it develop the knight and
bring the ropes into the game it should
be it should be very good for him but
capablanca goes Queen to d7 now
defending his knights on a cup of lanka
is up a piece and retty castles so the
king is in the center of the board
Bishop holds a very nice diagonal rook
is coming to e1 what can capablanca do
here kappa blanka plays Bishop to b7
preparing some discoveries although
there aren't all that many nasty
discoveries at the moment and now Bishop
to g7 forcing the roof to move and the
roof doesn't really have a good square
since g8 is covered by the Queen and f/8
and h8 are covered by the bishop but
it's not a problem Capablanca just
castles Queen side he gives up a rope he
says okay I'm up material you can have
that rook we have Bishop captures an 88
by reti and now Knight to e5 opening up
a discovery and also unleashing the
these bishops potential on this huge
diagonal weave Queen back to d1 by ready
and now feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the winning move
for Capablanca in this position while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a
beautiful unforeseen move and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
if you found Luke g8 that's perfectly
fine if you found Knight to f3 that's
perfectly fine but if you found the move
capablanca played then you get extra
points for for a good good measure you
know Bishop to f3 and it's it's I just
enjoy an unfortunate move more than
forcing why not the three chair pockets
it forces matters but this is just you
you say to white there's nothing you can
do here and it was in fact in this
position that each of the red resigned a
game and a wonderful victory for
Capablanca
yeah the game is from 1927 forgot to
mention that because now whatever you do
you could move the Queen lets the Queen
to d2 now you just get Queen to g4 and
there's no stopping mate you can play g3
Queen h3 again there is no stopping
Queen G to mate so what you can do after
Bishop checks you can play pawn captures
and now of course you see the
continuation for capablanca if you found
rook g8 check that doesn't work that's
at most a draw for black because after
king each one and Quinta h3 threatening
mate you're just gonna play rook to g1
now threatening to capture the rook and
now after a trade here captures captures
you don't have time to go to go for the
attack if Knight captures an f3 just
Queen g2 everything is fine and if Queen
captures and I three are gonna block and
here black will have to settle for a
perpetual as there is nothing better so
what you have to find here after this
Bishop turfs remove G captures and Queen
to h3 right away
now what doesn't have time for King to
h1 and there is no defense against rook
to g8 mate well once you give up some
material it will be made and if you're
playing h1 now Knight captures on f3 is
deadly because the only way to prevent
mate well you can't really really permit
prevent that you can postpone it by
playing Queen captures on a3 but that's
just pointless you're the Queen just
captures on f1 and that's again again
mate so you could do that but it would
be pointless so after the shop to f3 a
ret resign the game and the wonderful
yet again victory for host several
capablanca I decided to finish the saga
with this brilliant win but you know
well we're definitely gonna have more
couple bunker games in the future we're
gonna cover some other tournaments as
well but as the end maybe I will add
those videos of course the Capablanca
saga playlist but for the moment this is
it and you are now before we open up our
poll where we will vote for the next big
saga feel free to suggest what you think
the next big saga should be by using
hash tag soccer suggestion and I will of
course read all of your comments before
deciding on the next saga and also if
you have some opinions on whether the
sagas should be this long as we've
covered Capablanca saga from january up
until octo
/ that's like a lot of time or you would
maybe prefer shorter sagas maybe a
tournament saga not a player saga you
know if you have any interesting
opinions do share them I will read all
of them and surely they will be
impactful on you know when I decide on
the next big saga that we will cover so
that's a the game that's the saga you
know if you haven't been watching the
saga from the beginning I will put a
link in the description below the first
thing you will see is the link that will
take it to all the videos from the
capablanca saga starting from his match
against one course of the Cuban national
champion up until this video here now so
you know if you have a grandpa that
missed a couple longer saga just you
know give him that link and say Dario
grandpa enjoyed a cup of Blanco saga or
or grandma you know whoever enjoys chess
but yeah I do hope you enjoyed the the
video the saga and and all of these ten
months that we've we've enjoyed with the
good stuff I hope more more good stuff
will come I would like to thank Pete
McDonald for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
we're starting off with the Isle of Man
tournament today
and of course eagerly awaiting for the
world on the next big saga thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day